each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so I'm very pleased to welcome Vikram
odd way to microsoft research today
Vikram is an associate professor at the
University of Illinois he's been doing a
variety of work in the area of language
implementation as well as computer
architecture and security and recently
he's been looking at techniques for
safely executing c and other kinds of
programs while still preserving the
safety invariance of those program
allowing people to program using these
kinds of languages and still preserving
the safety and variance so with that
I'll turn it over to Vikram thank you
thank you all for coming I'm happy to be
here it's been I think four or five I'm
sorry it's been almost six years since I
last came to Microsoft Research and gave
a talk but it's been a great day I've
made a lot of interesting people I'm
going to tell you about a project that
we have been working on in my group that
I see as potentially becoming a fairly
broad area of research for us and we
call it secure virtual architecture and
I will tell you more about it as we go
along this is joint work with a research
programmer in my group John Criswell who
really has led the OS side of the work
and graduate students the knocker
Samantha Andrew and bull priests and
there have been other people who have
either developed techniques that we have
built on in previous research so chris
lattner built the olivium compile
infrastructure and and underlying point
analysis and program transformation to
be used in this work a couple of people
have worked with us on the interface
between the kernel and our virtual
architecture pierce alberta and david
ruler and we've had input and feedback
from other faculty at Illinois Siam King
and Roy Campbell so the broad context
for this work is that the threats to
system software to operating systems and
all of the privileged processes that run
on top of an operating system
or in fact includes that need to
preserve security or increasing even
though security procedures are getting
better people are patches are being
released and installed increasingly more
effectively tools are getting better
detect problems but the problem is that
the financial incentives to attack
systems to exploit them to extract data
and many other things are increasing
very strongly and this is potentially a
huge new threat that could happen to
computer systems that but you see
examples of this already but it could
grow even further and one important
consideration that you have to take into
account when you're talking about
security for systems today or for the
foreseeable future is that the vast
majority of them are written in c plus C
or C++ so on safe languages and this is
not only true of long term systems is
even true of new completely Riyadh newly
developed highly secure systems like
secure 64 which is a start of building
highly secure operating systems for
things like DNS servers and others it's
obviously true for commodity operating
systems like Windows Linux Mac OS and
BSD family it's also true for the
services that run on many commodity
systems today and of course for service
like Apache and find out the names which
is a new server I'm sorry a change that
last night and of course I didn't fix
that bullet there and one important
issue that that to keep in mind is that
the techniques that are being introduced
in production systems to deal with with
security problems in these kinds of
systems are ad hoc partial solutions
that that things like marking stack or
data not executable or software fault
injection that tries to apply sandboxing
on
software things like that and these are
very limited partial solutions they
don't come close to eliminating the
kinds of security holes are you that can
exist in systems today so one vision
that's been held for for quite a long
time is the division of running and a
complete operating system and system
services in a safe execution environment
because safe execution environments
eliminate a large class of security
holes things like buffer overflows
dangling pointers and others they also
improve system reliability because you
eliminate those programming errors and
in some ways perhaps most important
running an OS and system software in a
safe programming environment gives you
the ability to you to incorporate novel
OS design techniques things that would
be difficult without that safe
programming environment and so research
projects have developed many such
techniques I have listed a bunch of
examples here but a couple of examples
that I will pick on our one is running
entire user processes in the kernel
address space like software Isis and
isolated processes in singularity or
allowing so the second example is
providing first-class support for
high-level language virtual machines in
the operating system itself because the
manager runtime features that you need
are integrated into the underlying
system framework there have been several
projects that have taken the stack that
have try to explore this vision but and
but to date all of the ones that I know
often I believe all of them rely on a
safe programming language so the early
systems like genera and others built on
operating systems for Less machines and
they wrote the systems and lists spin
used modular three there have been
operating systems written in Java
singularities written using C sharp in
all these cases the research projects
led to many novel OS design techniques
and that's valuable research but it's
difficult to transition those ideas into
commodity kernels that
widely used today because those kernels
are not written and do not run in a safe
execution environment so what we have
been trying to do is to develop a
virtual architecture a virtual machine
and an interface to the virtual machine
that allows you to run a complete OS in
all of its software as well as any
subset of applications that you choose
potentially all of them on top of a on
top of the virtual machine and all of
the code that runs on the worst machine
is compiled to a virtual instruction set
and that virtual instruction set is then
translated to the native instruction set
of the underlying processor
transparently typically offline we there
is no specific reason to have to do this
online although you could if you chose
and just to break down that box a little
the definition of this virtual
architecture includes an API that
provides access to hardware resources
including process state control
operations at hardware control
operations that a kernel typically needs
to manage hardware resources and
underlying that is the implementation
which we call an execution engine that
includes the capabilities like code
generation safety checking and
potentially techniques to optimize and
profile code that is running on top of
this virtual machine and this execution
engine uses a simple API that's OS
independent and mud and would have we
implemented by any particular OS porter
to it to cash a data offline that can
include native translation of code
that's generated from the virtual object
code you can include profile data if
that's useful for profile of an
execution but that's an optional
capability the caching is not strictly
required for the system
so that's the goal of the work is to be
able to run legacy corners like Linux
and others by porting them to this
virtual instruction set and this API and
what's important about this is I think
there are there are a wide range of
interesting benefits of doing of running
a system like this I've broken them into
two categories and then there's a third
category of things that we cannot deal
with but I'm focusing here on security
problems just because that's one
important area where I think a motion
machine like this could have significant
impact the first class of problems are
problems that you would expect to be
solved by using a safe language or a
safe execution environment and these are
well-known things like buffer overflows
and format string errors and other ones
like that there's also a second category
of off silly of systems of problems
where the compiler based virtual machine
underlying the system could enable new
solutions these are not new problems
with the solutions you could take to
address them can be new and these
include things like applications are
running with excessive privilege and
programs trying to protect application
data from from being visible to the
underlying operating system detecting
kernel-mode rootkits securely in a way
that cannot be tampered with even by
injected code that got colonel access
and many others so there are a number of
high-level security problems that I
think could be addressed by this kind of
framework there are also problems that
would not be that may not be
significantly helped by this kind of
framework you would probably need
extensive application level solutions
for them and they're not really goals of
our work but those first two categories
I think or things that we could start
exploring using this kind of framework
in this talk I mean one second I'll come
back to you in this talk I'm primarily
going to focus on the design of the
virtual architecture the underlying
virtual machine and how we
achieve this achieve a safe execution
environment I am I'll briefly touch on
higher level security problems and a
couple of high level security problems
that we can address and discuss them
towards the end of the talk but this is
in my mind of an EDF that's wide open
for research for the first look to be a
very much like a redo of the V old vm
372 the change of virtual machine
language so is it so IBM I think you're
right in the sense that IBM was the
first to really develop a whole
framework that allowed so they had this
language called the machine interface
that actually started in the early IBM
africana the first machine that had it
but it was later called new machine
language they allow so they have a whole
layer of translation from machine from
the machine interface down to native
hardware one of the big differences I
thinks if I go back to the picture here
one of the big differences is that their
virtual machine their compiler framework
for doing the translation and a lot of
the other runtime support was actually
tightly integrated into the operating
system itself so they had so an
operating system had a bunch of code
that ran above the interface and a lot
of code that ran below the interface
even databases so they had strong
support for database execution in the
virtual machine itself fundamentally
their virtual instruction set was
co-designed with the operating system
and even with important class of
applications like database systems it
would be very difficult to try and host
one of those environments on top of a
processor today what we are trying to do
here is define something that's much
smaller and more compact and is designed
to run on today's processors and run
today software
so what I'm going to do in this talk is
spend a few slides giving you a
high-level overview of what SVA is and
how it operates then describe the
virtual instruction set and the compiler
framework we use in the virtual machine
then discuss the safety guarantees that
we provide and how we achieve them and
then briefly talk about other future
security applications of the framework
so this is a picture of how you would
port an existing system to the virtual
machine to the secure virtual
architecture and this is how we've
ported a version of the Linux kernel to
dot 2422 route 422 in our group so you
essentially what what you have to do is
take the existing operating system and
port the kernel to the API for
privileged operations that we have
defined and at the end of that port you
would have a kernel with no assembly
coordinate you would have no native code
native machine code that's directly part
of the kernel itself all hardware level
resources are accessed through this API
and a second thing you have to do is
poor Conal allocators to a checker
interface that we define that allows us
to perform the safety the runtime safety
checks that we need to enforce memory
safety and the other safety guarantees
and you would then put that compiler
through AC let me put that system
through a safety checking compiler that
simply checking compiler does a
collection of static checks and then
inserts so and then generates a the
operating system in SVA in the virtual
instruction set we call that bytecode
this bytecode for the operating system
includes type annotations that describe
the safety properties that the OS is
intended to satisfy so the compiler
generates those safety annotations which
are essentially a type system yeah
this floating that depends heavily on
the operating system and how well its
portability interface is defined I would
think that for linux so we ported linux
incrementally as we were defining this
design this API itself so so the time
that we took is not represented for
anything starting from scratch with this
API I would think a person could do it
in a matter of perhaps two to three
months one person in two to three months
I think that would be feasible you might
not get a complete port in that much
time but you'd get a sufficient port
that you could run it on the system and
one thing i should say is that in our
port we have not ported the bootloader
over so the bootloader still runs as
native code there's no technical reason
why we could not do that it's just not
something that was me necessary for any
of the research that we are doing you
know so goodness have some automated
tools which would capture the calls from
the color and then seidel method
you could try to do that it's you would
need to have a very detailed and
accurate description of the semantics
between the architecture and independent
part of the kernel and the architecture
dependent part so you so you know a
clean interface is not enough you need a
lot of description of the semantics of
that interface to do the porting you
could you could certainly develop tools
that would simplify the porting but it's
not something that we've thought about
and and personally I'm not sure that's
actually terribly important if it was
important people who would have done it
for operating systems already today
because this porting effort is something
that that operating systems go through
on a periodic basis any other questions
ok so then running this operating system
on the virtual architecture goes like
this so we take the OS that's been
compiled to SVA bytecode run it through
what we call a verifier which is in our
case simply a type checker and then and
this type checker also puts in runtime
checks for the cases that cannot be
completely checked statically and that
code is then passed to a code generator
which generates native code links the
dead code is linked with the library
implementing the privileged operations
you don't actually need to do this as a
library if you if you prefer you can
since since the semantics of this
library is well defined and known to the
compiler the compiler could actually
incorporate operations from this library
optimize them for a particular
architecture and you may not necessarily
need to provide them through a library
but conceptually this is just an API
implemented by a library and then you
would you would boot that system and
that you could write the compiled and
checked OS in native code out to disk at
this point and read it back as long as
you have some way of ensuring that that
that image is not corrupted so you need
to cryptographically sign it and check
it when you read it
to make sure it's not been tampered with
and that's how we how we expect systems
to run on this environment one important
point here is that these steps which are
all part of the trusted computing base
for our system archons are technically
significantly simpler than the safety
safety checking compiler itself that
compiler does fairly sophisticated
interprocedural analysis and
transformations to achieve the safety
guarantees that we provide with low
overhead and so on and our system is
designed deliberately to take that
safety checking compiler out of the
trusted computing base and only having a
simple a bytecode verifier a simple type
checker in fact in here but the second
benefit besides eliminating the besides
reducing the trusted code bases that
these two operations are not
interprocedural they are purely they are
the operator function in fact the type
checker is purely local and so these can
be done incrementally on modules or
components that are dynamically loaded
into the kernel the checking can be done
incremental at install time or load time
but that allows as an engineering issue
this that's extremely important for
real-world systems so I just take it to
some of the key design features that we
have it attempted to have nsv a number
one we want the system to the the
security guarantees the safety checking
techniques to be comprehensive you we
want to apply them to all security
sensitive software on the system
including the kernel OS extensions
device drivers all of the demons
important libraries like SSL potentially
all of the applications it what
applications are included in that set or
up to a system administrator who can
choose if necessary on all applications
through this environment second we want
the security checking to be
incontrovertible
that I mean that it cannot be bypassed
by any software that runs on this system
so and the way you achieve this is by
having the installer which is logically
part of the operating system perform any
safety checking operation that it wants
to do using the virtual machine as
essentially a library so any safety
checks are either the operating system
or the virtual machine wants to enforce
can be done and will be done at install
time or load time third we wanted to be
robust and and by that I simply mean
making the trusted computing base as
small as possible we've really only
we've taken 11 step in that direction by
taking out secure the safety checking
compiler I think we could go further for
example taking out the native code
generator by using a typed assembly
language for the machine code that is
generated so this is an incremental
process but I think that's an important
goal as well Thor forth and this is a
property that that the system has even
though we don't exploit in any way right
now the it's a whole system environment
what I mean by that is that compiler
techniques runtime monitoring and so on
can apply across traditional boundaries
like the boundary between an application
and the kernel or across multiple
applications that might be interacting
by compiling everything down to this
uniform virtual instruction set that's
designed for good analysis and
transformation we can apply
sophisticated compiler techniques across
these boundaries so for example we've
done a simple experiment where we
extended a colonel with new system calls
with specialized versions of existing
system calls is the right that's right
way to think about it for a specific
application and effectively that allowed
us to exploit constant arguments that
existed in that application that's a
very simple example but it shows that
you can you can do these kinds of whole
system transformations and the last one
is that the system the design can
exploit hardware
cysts that are now starting to emerge as
standard so you so a trusted platform
module gives you a way to do what's
called secure boot so you can securely
you can boot a system and authenticate
all of the software what's called a
chain of trust that goes from from step
to step during that boot process and the
later process of working applications
you can also use what's called an iommu
which is essentially support hardware
support to check DMA to run DMA through
page through the paging system so that
you can apply operating system
protections to dma as well and not many
people realize this but in fact today
DMA is essentially unsafe you can DMA
operations can over at any part of
memory even on on a hypervisor based
system like VMware or Zen so we've
developed a prototype of this framework
it includes an implementation of the
pravasi API a library that that is
written in C and x86 assembly code and
it's compiled to into a native library
ahead of time and linked into a colonel
we've implemented a set of safety safety
checking compiler that actually came out
of an earlier project called safe code
the earlier project focused on
standalone programs we are now extending
that to work on the kernel and we
provide the same safety guarantees for
both standalone programs and the colonel
and when I said that we have an
untrusted safety checking compiler we've
also ported to Linux kernel to this it
looks just like a port to a new
architecture it just happens to be a
virtual architecture and in fact that
makes it significantly simpler than then
porting to a typical hardware
architecture like x86 or something else
all there is no assembly code left in
this ported in this portrait colonel
accepting the bootloader which logically
is not part of the Kundalini case and we
have in doing the sport we treat
specific allocators as we treat the
Colonel's allocators as pre existing
pool alligators and I'll talk about why
that's important later on in the talk
here so that was an overview of the
system let me talk about the virtual
instruction set and the compiler system
the motion instruction set has two parts
to it there's the unprivileged
operations that are used for most of the
code computations and those operations
are derived directly from a compiler
system called llvm in fact it is simply
the virtual the bytecode representation
and internal representation used by the
olivium infrastructure I will say a
little bit more about that I just have
one slide on that we have extended that
representation with a type system to
encode the safety properties we are
enforcing and this is a this same extent
this kind of extension can be done for
other security annotations if there are
the security properties that you want to
enforce by by doing it ahead of time
analysis and transformation and then
doing a type checker running a type
checker at install time or load time the
privileged operations go through an API
that manages all colonel hardware
interactions and the most important
thing point about that API is that it
only defines mechanisms that a kernel
will need to run on a particular piece
of hardware it does not dictate any
policy so all policy decisions are left
entirely to the kernel itself
the compiler foundation for the virtual
machine comes from our previous project
called llvm the the original research
goal of llvm was to provide a foundation
for what we call life long compilation
being able to do sophisticated compiler
techniques at any stage of the lifetime
of a program and that goes from initial
compile time through link time install
time load time runtime as well as what
we call idle time which is between
executions on the end user's machine and
fundamentally the way you achieve that
is by using a persistent code
representation that is designed for
effective optimization so what I mean by
that is I think a good way to think
about this is contrast this with Java by
Java Virtual Machine bytecode JVM
bytecode is a relatively high level
language it is also persistent and you
can analyze and transform it at all
points at all the points in time that is
available but there are many low-level
transformations you cannot perform on it
because it does not expose lower level
operations like for example they
implement the implementation of a
virtual function call isn't exposed at
the Java Virtual Machine level all those
kinds of implementation details are
exposed in this IR as it turns out that
research project has taken on a life of
its own it's now being used by quite a
few companies some companies including
apple and adobe are using it as a
just-in-time compiler there are other
companies like create that are using it
as a static back-end to generate static
to do static code generation both of
these users also do mid-level
optimization ahead of time so in a sense
this lifelong compilation capability is
is being exploited to in a limited way
by these companies already but the
important thing about that is that it
gives us a commercial quality
infrastructure into which a lot of
investment is going on and the software
is available llvm to RG it's fully or if
we distribute under liberal open-source
license all the development that happens
on it at least at Apple
as well as all the other open source
projects using it or contributed back to
the external to our CVS or running at
Illinois so you can get you can benefit
from all the investments that are
happening on it and if you are
interested to try it out the software is
available llvm go to RG sorry that was a
quick commercial for llvm but getting
back to the point here so the virtual
instruction set for our virtual machine
includes several features I won't go
through all of the detailed examples
here this is just an example that shows
a simple C fragment of code that's
compiled to the olivium instruction set
the important features here are first
the operations are low level so it's a
it is a simple load store architecture
with with a with a set of virtual
registers that's an unlimited set about
two registers the virtual registrar that
in static single assignment form and so
we have explicit fee operations to
represent the SS a form here and that
allows us that gives us a basis to do
data flow analysis on this code it's a
type representation it essentially
includes a subset of the types that the
C programming language gives you it
includes structures arrays pointers and
functions as well as all of this
primitive types and that's the
essentially a kind of mid-level type in
fluent but but it's rich enough to be
able to do sophisticated point analysis
dependence analysis and program
transformations directly on this
representation the privileged operations
are not you're not going to say a whole
lot about them I just have one slide
here they're in you can divide them into
two categories there are hardware
control operations like operations to
register system call handlers interrupt
handler strap and laws and so on and
that these registration operations allow
us to monitor all entry all entries into
the operating system simply their
operations register page table entries
that allows to monitor all page mapping
in events and similarly fire operations
the second category is state
manipulation operations
allow the colonel to save and restore
state during a context switch for
example and one important feature there
is that the colonel directly saves and
restores native state not virtual state
it essentially gets a bag of bytes that
represent the native state of the
underlying code in order to avoid
overhead of translating back into
virtual state add context switches and
other operations like signaled a livery
which also requires setting up some data
and then doing a context switch an
interrupt context that allows us to do
very efficiently field interrupts by
exploiting hardware support for this
these are the kinds of operations that
are provided in this API so that's all I
have to say about the virtual
instruction set if there are any
questions I'd be happy to stop and take
them I have many more slides with with
details and one thing I should warn you
is this is going to be a very high-level
talk so if people are interested in more
details I'd be happy to put apps do it
after one round of questions or just
towards the end of the talk if you are
interested so what I'm going to talk
about next are the safety guarantees
that we provide and the principles by
which we achieve them the safety
guarantee that we try to provide and one
thing to keep in mind is we are trying
to do this for unmodified C programs for
in this in the case of standalone
programs in the case of the Cardinal the
only modification be required is porting
the colonel alligators to our checkout
interface in order to preserve the
colonel alligators so what we what we
provide our guarantees that are close to
what a safe language to provide provides
which is very strong for sea but it's
still not quite equal to a safe language
and I'll come back to that but that
includes memory safely so for example
you never use uninitialized pointers you
never have pareo flows so array bounds
violations we guarantee type safety for
a subset of the objects in a program and
I'll characterize that i'll explain that
in little more detail later we enforce
control flow integrity and specifically
what I mean by that is that the
executing code will never take an
execution paths that was not predicted
by the compiler
and we also guarantee a sound
operational semantics for C code this is
something that not a lot of people think
about in practice but in fact C
compilers are essentially not sound
because memory safety violations like a
dangling pointer buffer overrun can
invalidate the assumptions of the
compiler makes in doing basic analyses
like point analysis like other data flow
transformations and other things and
optimizing compilers essentially say
that there are no guarantees if if one
of those memory safety violations
occurred that's not good enough for a
safety checking compiler it's also not
good not good enough for analysis tools
like static checking tools that aim to
give some kind of guarantee of that a
particular property is satisfied by the
code so we're able to guarantee a sound
operational semantics that allows you to
do sound static analysis on C code
despite the possibility of dangling
pointer errors so that that brings me to
the major weakness compared with a safe
language and I should emphasize this
weakness is by design we do not
eliminate dangling pointer errors and we
do that deliberately because we're
trying to avoid the need to run a
garbage collector in in these
environments or vote for any of the sea
for any of the sea software and so we so
dangling pointer errors can occur but we
do still guarantee that all of these
properties are satisfied and that's what
I so i can so i say have to be tolerated
angling pointer errors we guarantee that
none of these properties will be
invalidated by a potential dangling
pointer error at runtime and I think in
many ways that's probably one of the
main intellectual contributions of the
safety part of this work is how to
provide this kind of guarantee which I
don't think any previous compiler has
provided we can also optionally detect
all dangling pointer uses it's a
technique that we've developed recently
that has low overhead for programs that
are not very allocation in
tensive it can have fairly high overhead
for allocation intensive programs but
still that over is in the order of 3x to
10x it's reasonable for debugging for
example it's significantly better than
Val grind or purify or tools like that
then you other that are to use today for
dangling pointers and the overhead is
actually low enough that for some
programs like UNIX demons we found its
you can use it for production code the
slowdowns are in the range of five to
ten percent for many of those kinds of
demons and overall one of the main goals
in developing our safety techniques is
to keep them practical the for
standalone programs as I said before
it's completely automatic it does not
require you to write wrappers to
interface with external libraries like
other compilers do so systems like seek
your and and save see in cyclone because
they use fat pointers cannot interface
automatically with external code always
they require to write some rappers to do
that and we've avoided that or those
systems also use garbage collection it
is secure in cyclone do or in the case
of cyclone they use a combination of
garbage collection and region based
memory management we have tried to avoid
the need for any kind of automatic
memory management because C programs are
really not written to make that very
effective and we have a result so we
have very low overhead for C programs
and I will describe these a little bit
later
so I'm just going to take you through
some of the underlying principles that
we use to achieve these safety
guarantees I think you know X describing
these in more detail I could do with an
additional 10 or 20 minutes and I'd be
happy to do that I have all the slides
that we need for that but if you have
any questions just let me know and if
you like I can go through it in more
detail later the first idea underlying
our safety techniques is that we
partition memory so we perform a program
transformation called automatic pool
allocation that wasn't purely a couple
of years ago that transforms a program
so that the memory used by the program
is logically partitioned into pools and
those partitions correspond to the
static partitions computed by a point
analysis so if you think of a point
analysis so think of a points to graph
computed by point analysis for example
typically the nodes in that graph
represent disjoint sets of memory
objects and in the graph then is
basically a static partitioning of the
objects created and access by the
program and these pools at runtime the
runtime pools correspond directly to the
compile time partitions created by the
point analysis and that gives us a
couple of important benefits so first we
can enforce sound point analysis by
performing what I call pool checks on
load and store operations and those pool
checks are much more efficient than if
you didn't do this pool allocation
transformation because in the original
program the memory the objects in a
particular points to set might be
scattered around in the heat in the heap
and stack and Global's and checking at a
pointer points to the correct set
intended set of objects would be
extremely expensive because we have a we
can we know what the logical pool that a
pointer variable is supposed to point to
and those pools are managed by our run
time we simply have to check a set of
contiguous pages for each such pool
check
this also allows to enforce partial type
safety so that I mentioned this point
earlier now points to graph during the
analysis can you can infer type
information for some of the nodes in a
points to graph essentially because the
pointer analysis is is examining all the
operations that potentially occur on a
on the points two nodes except for nodes
there are access accessible by external
code so for some subset of nodes we're
examining all the operations and we know
which that subset is and we can check
whether all those operations obey a
certain data type and if they do then we
mark that points to set as a as a as a
set that's type of modulus first type is
known at compile time and for that for
any object that map to those sets we
guarantee type safety in the system the
second idea here is to exploit these
typos Madonna spools as for performance
optimization so we can eliminate all
runtime checks on loads and stores to
these typos modular spoons because
essentially at compile time we have
examined all the operations on those
pools so essentially we have done a
static check to guarantee that those
operations are type safe the only
exception here then is array bounds
checking so the type checker cannot
guarantee you that you don't violate the
bounds of an array in one of these pools
and so you need runtime checks for that
but we get rid of all of the checks and
loads and stores to these pools the
second important benefit here is that
dangling pointers become harmless for a
pool that's typo modulus as long as you
add one important constraint at runtime
which is that you align all objects and
identical boundaries so essentially what
happens is an old object and a new
object in the same logical pool will
either overlap perfectly or not at all
and when I say well I perfectly I mean
all of their fields so the component
values will align correctly and so a
dangling pointer that will touch in 10
to access the old object but happens to
access a new one will never create any
type conversions any unintended type
conversions in the code and so the
dangling so dangling pointers become
harmless essentially for free for these
type of modulus pools for non type of
modulus pools we have to do the runtime
checks on loads and stores to ensure
that they have that they target the
right pool and runtime checks and array
bounds operations to make sure that you
don't violate array bounds the third
inside we've had here is that we can
perform array bounds checking very
effectively without adding metadata on
pointers and this is an issue that takes
a couple of self steps to explain but
the the problem here is we want to
ensure that array indexing operations
are safe in C and in see a point of a
point to an orbit relocation in the
middle of an array so taking a point of
value at runtime you do not know where
the start or end of the object is so
there is no easy way like in Java to go
to the header and find the expected
bounds the intended bounds of that
pointer and this is sometimes called
identifying the referent object for a
pointer that's the difficult part of the
cincy question
do some other time are you talking about
this bounce checking are you talking
about the whole go over all of those in
general going to object a and I just
something I love you reinvention
reinterpreted at me right so essentially
what we do there is so forth one thing
to realize is that in those cases those
objects will fall in pools are not type
of modulus because you will if you
performed operations using both those
types if you simply cause something to
void star and back or even cost a child
star and back or something like that and
don't do any any operations using the
child star that we just ignore that but
if you do any actual operations like
array indexing structure indexing or a
load or store using a pointer type then
using both types then the pool will not
be type of modulus so we don't guarantee
any type safety for those objects and
presumably the program or intent
deliberately wrote that cost and we are
not you know we're essentially
preserving the semantics of the program
and we're giving a guarantee that is
weaker than what safe languages would
give you but save languages are simply
disallow these kinds of costs right any
other questions every bounce checks how
to do with
the inline array an object that contains
environme so an array inside a structure
yeah so so let me explain how we do it
for any array and it includes in line
arrays there's no difference but the so
so coming back to the problem I was
saying that an array bounds checking for
see the problem is finding an intended
target object of a pointer one way to do
this is to is to add metadata to every
pointer variable every point of value at
one time that tracks the intended bones
and this is what several previous
systems do this is what C cure does
cyclone safe see all of them use
metadata on point of values and the
problem is that changes the logical
point of representation and now you
cannot interface this code directly with
external libraries without at least in
some cases having to write wrappers
manually an alternative way which was
originally proposed by Jones and Kelly
is to not add any metadata pointers but
maintain a lookup table of all the
objects that are created by a program
during execution and maintain the
invariant that a pointer always points
within the bounds of its object so you
so you initialize a point at a point or
certain object and from that point on in
all pointer arithmetic operations you
ensure it stays within the bounds of its
expected object and if you think about
that for a minute you do you realize the
overhead of that is extremely high and
their overheads ranged so that the over
of that technique range from 4 X 2 11 x
slowdowns to get these kinds of to get
to do bounds checking obviously is going
to be a little hard to convince people
to use that kind of technique but one
inside the be had is that we could bring
the bring the overheads down greatly if
instead of using one large lookup table
for all the allocated objects in the
program we could use several small
tables and fundamentally the original
pool allocation transformation gives you
exactly that it gives you logical pools
that partition memory into smaller sets
so we maintain one look up look up table
poor pool
and the important thing here is that we
know at compile time for every point of
variable which pool to check because
that's something that we've enforced
during the pool allocation
transformation and so we know which
table to check we can do look up in that
table and that greatly reduces the
overhead in fact we also added a couple
of other optimizations along with that
which could have been done in previous
work too but just wasn't and together we
bring down the overheads to the range of
ten to twenty percent for most programs
we've had a worst-case no instance of
the worst case we've seen so far as like
sixty-nine percent overhead for one
program thats quiet array intensive but
you get a dramatic reduction in overhead
and we're avoiding meta data on pointers
in the program the point is with
reference through objects from muscles
this type of multiple pools no betting
no no so different types and
so so this transformation a fork or
automatic food allocation that works
with the unification based point of
analysis so we have a at compile time we
have an invariant that the every point
of points to only a single node in the
points to graph a single points to set
essentially and that's a constraint on
the kinds of techniques that we can
infer for which we can guarantee
soundness if the point i could
quantitate in multiple data structures
here can heineken know in multiple
flockhart you would you date it from
both structures in the same yes exactly
so all the objects are potentially
pointed to by a common point of will and
end up in a single pool yeah as possible
somehow rewriting the program
Rochester outside about me
so you mean for this for the bounds
checking work here that's a good
collection here so the question here was
is the programmer responsible for
rewriting programs if a program it does
indexing that goes out of the bounds of
an object and potentially comes back in
bounds before being used so in other
words it's not an illegal operation
because the pointers not used while it's
out of bounds is that right and the
programmer is not responsible for that
in fact of large part of the overheads
in previous work was exactly for that
there was an extension to the Jones and
Kelly work by by reversing learn who
showed how to do that safely and what
they do is they use a separate lookup
table for these would be called out of
bounds pointers and that was one of the
optimizations that that we have done it
made it much more effective essentially
what we do is when a pointer goes out of
bounds we replace that point of value by
an illegal address that would cause a
segfault if you actually used it but
then maintained a lookup table from the
address of that point or to the bonds of
the original object so now if the
pointer comes back into bounds we can
replace it back again with the original
point with the original we can repeat
the original metadata any other
questions
so I'm just going to talk about so give
you a quick summary of the experiments
we've done to measure the runtime
overheads of this framework we've these
numbers include to benchmark so it's
olden and pointer dist which are both
pointer intensive sets of programs and
we've also looked at a collection of
system demons the full list is in this
paper cited here we did not require any
source code changes for any of these
programs this was fully automatic and
the array bounds checking technique was
able to detect all attacks from a suite
that was developed by someone calls it
so that models a number of reported
exploits that have been there I've
occurred on on system software and so
the table here lists a subset of the
programs the rest are in the paper these
include the worst cases for for all
these suites and the overheads without
the array bounds check so as it turns
out we can guarantee sound analysis
without doing precise array bounds
checks the sound analysis only requires
that we guarantee that pool bounds are
satisfied so we can ensure ensure the
pond analysis sound simply by checking
pool bounds and not individual array
bounds if you want fine again memory
safety and you can turn on the array
checks without the array checks the
worst-case overheads we've seen or
thirty percent for ya core two twenty
three percent for anagram most of the
other cases I'm sorry twenty-seven
percent for en 3d mostly other cases are
zero three seven percent yeah if you
turn on the array checks then some of
the overheads get much worse so for
example en 3d goes from twenty-seven
percent to ninety-one percent and that's
there's one bad or a reference that's in
an innermost loop and we were only able
to pull out the bounced check I think
out of one level of loop or something
like that and so you get potentially
very significant overhead if you're
running for example a scientific program
which is
with a lot of array operations this is
using llvm system as the baseline this
is comparing against yes it's using
enthusing llvm as the baseline without
the pool allocation transformation and
none of the safety checking passes the
safety checking compiler by the way is
called safe code I didn't introduce that
name before yeah that's a good question
so um so the this is an exegesis yeah so
I many variations
so that there are differences in code
Laird when you turn on the array checks
versus when you do not and that's the
only explanation I have right now for
why the performance change there how
BIG's drink these programs are ya these
are not very big program so these
programs are in the range of sort of the
golden programs are in the range of a
few hundred to an order of about a
thousand lines of code the pointer does
programs go up to I think ten thousand
lines of code that's the largest one is
about that big the demons I think gee
httpd is in the order of a couple it's
on order of thousands of lines of code
any other questions
oops so just a quick comparison we
compare this with secured on the old and
pointed us benchmarks and if you look at
the secret numbers it has much higher
time overheads except on en 3d where it
benefits because it has the fat pointer
representation so it doesn't have to do
the lookups for for object tables it has
much higher space overheads because
they're using a conservative garbage
collector and they reported space over
words of up to 4x for some of their
programs and they described in detail
some of the porting effort that's
required if you look at the top last
paper that was needed to run the older
and pointer dis benchmarks on C cured
what was the baseline for that person
their comparison was so what I'm
comparing there are the reported
percentage slowdowns with C cured versus
without secured using a common common
back in compiler and I do not remember
what back in compiler they used so I'm
comparing their percentages versus our
percentages which are not uncommon
baselines I understand that so you have
to take this with a grain of salt but I
think that if you look at the the whole
set of numbers and look at the pattern
there is a clear pattern in the
differences between the numbers in both
cases the experiments isolate the
slowdowns due to the due to the safety
checking techniques so I think it's
actually a reasonable comparison any
other questions
so these techniques that we originally
developed in the safe code project for
standalone programs need significant
extensions to work on a kernel and I'll
talk a little bit about that here
perhaps most importantly colonel you
Colonels use many custom allocators
they're all cool alligators of one sort
or another but the important point is
that they that these alligators are
required for correctness not just for
performance they're preserving their
enforcing properties like pinning pages
in memory or alignment requirements and
other things that would be difficult to
reproduce in using an automatic
transformation like pool allocation so
so we did not want to try and run
automatic pool allocation on the kernel
code and include a new pool alligator
above the Colonel's memory management
itself so we basically retain all
existing colonel alligators and we
define a clean interface so there are
two things we have to do your one the
easy part is we define a clean interface
between the alligator and the checker
which does the runtime checks so the
alligator notifies the checker for the
information needed like objects that are
allocated or deallocated or pages of
memory that are retrieved from the
underlying system the much more
complicated and conceptually difficult
part is what to do with this the
compilers safety checking passes so the
the trick that we are using here is
essentially to infer a mapping from the
Colonel's alligator the Colonel's pools
not alligators the Colonel's fools to
the points to graph nodes that we derive
in our point analysis so we run a
pointer answer in the kernel constructor
points to graph we have to be informed
of the allocation function used in our
functions used in each of those
alligators we treat those as allocation
entry points in order to match logical
pools in the kernel to the points to
graph nodes and essentially then the
rest of our safety checking techniques
were
as before we maintain metadata for the
pools at runtime we one important thing
we have take into account is that
sometimes you will get multiple colonel
pools for a single node in the points to
graph that's a case where the point
analysis was not precise enough to
distinguish those pools and so we
actually create something we call meta
pools to track sets of pools at runtime
is one meta pool / points to graph node
and all the checking techniques I
described earlier happens for meta pool
so that's one major extension that we've
had to do a second one is that kernels
have many external entry points many
more than a standard program that
includes interrupts traps and system
calls and some of those entry points can
bring in pointers to external objects
into the kernel for example buffers that
get passed in through a system call and
four points to graph so the problem that
that the way the compiler sees this
problem is your points to graph node
that's accessible from external code in
fact from a pointer that comes in
through some external interface and
therefore that the corresponding logical
pool should include objects that were
actually allocated externally so for
example by user code but which would not
have been registered in the pool and so
we would get false positives at runtime
essentially we would declare safety
violations when in fact it's a perfectly
safe operation so in those cases we have
to turn off some runtime checks we can
still perform checks and all the array
indexing operations because those checks
look for an existing object and then
decide if the pointer increment the next
thing operation violate the bonds of the
object so if the object simply doesn't
exist we just ignore that but if an
object does exist we can enforce the
bounds for it third so there are the
minor issues well the third one is a
minor issue the fourth one is not but
the third one is that early in the boot
sequence you don't even have memory
available you have no none of the
alligators might be available to use
directly and so for example we need to
create allocate memory or have access to
memory to store metadata for objects
essentially we have to reserve
some physical memory oil in the boot
process to deal with this issue but it's
an example of the kinds of things that
are just different in a colonel from
user from application code and there's
extensive use of non typesafe code in
the in the kernel and so we're we are
having to make both our static array
bounds checking which by the way was not
included in those previous numbers all
the previous numbers i showed you do not
include any static array bounds checking
at all we are using static array bounds
checking and in fact trying to make it
more aggressive than what we had in the
system earlier and do additional runtime
tuning to try and handle the way it's
introduced by these so this is very much
a work in progress at this point and we
have a working prototype and we are
working on both making it more robust
and doing performance tuning and and
also trying to decrease the number of
checks we have to eliminate because of
having external externally accessible
pools sorry so the last slide I have
done on the safety principles is on
verifying the security of SV a bytecode
I don't have a lot more detail to add
here except that the type system that we
use to encode the safety properties is a
relatively simple region based type
system it we derive we got a number of
techniques directly from the cyclone
type system and use them here the tides
essentially include a stack of regions
the region's essentially are the logical
pools that we have inferred and every
object is registered in one of those
regions so it's legit on one of those
pools and we have a region annotation on
the type for every pointer variable that
encodes what region is supposed to point
to and that type system then is checked
by a simple local type checker which
also insert the runtime checks these are
the checks that I described earlier so
we change all the stagger regions as in
chocolate
so you are actually able to reclaim
pools yes and the way you're able to do
that is because we construct a points to
graph you can do reach ability analysis
on the points to graph so you can
evaluate for example at any point in the
code like a function return is a pool or
functionality for that matter is a pool
accessible from any pointers that are
live outside that function that includes
global variables incoming arguments and
the return value and if the pool is
reachable from any of those then the
function then the pool is still live on
return from the function if it's not
reachable then we can reclaim the pool
completely in terms of garbage
collection beach ability as opposed to
for example sometimes our hands like use
a pair that they had bailout angry
orders 2 onions to pose the reclaim vs
as long as they could prove that they
were not used anymore that's it so
there's no reason why we could not do
the same thing we could do more
sophisticated analysis or current
analysis only does reach ability like
garbage collection each ability but of
course doing it statically on the points
to do so it's quite emphasized it's
quite conservative so for example I had
a global variable point into a pool we
would unless we did additional analysis
you would never know if that who became
their own
one important thing which I said before
is that the checks performed by the type
checker are so are local to fungal
individual functions and one interesting
point I want to make sure is that this
strategy of performing the safety checks
ahead of time and then doing the type
checking in a bytecode verifier can be
used for any security properties that
can be encoded as type systems and so
for example it can so they would walk
around at a very nice paper in purple
2000 showing how security automata which
are a class of security problems defined
by fred schneider at cornell he showed
that security automata could be
represented as as types and andy Myers
had or has done extensive work on
encoding information flow properties in
type systems and you could do those
kinds of security properties in the same
framework and in a robust way yeah it is
desirable just as a homogeneous groups
no well ok so that's a good question so
if you needed a type information for
individual objects in other pools then
it would apply only to the homogeneous
pools if you needed type information
only for entire collections of objects
like like the entire the set of objects
in the points to note then that
restriction wouldn't occur and in fact I
think to take some of these type systems
and figure out how to use them in on top
of SVA is a research problem if you want
to do it for arbitrary C code that's not
type safe and hard to analyze if you
were running type safe code on top of
this environment you might not have this
problem at all and so you could
effectively would you could you could
engineer design a system so you only had
type of modulus pools in those cases
okay so I was going to talk briefly
about a couple of future security
applications of SVA but I'm running over
time here so i think i will skip that
and i just leave you with the key inside
here which is that in this in this
system this is the same slide from
before with just one additional comment
which is that the system gives us a
compiler and a privileged runtime that
underlies all of the code that's
executing on executing on this system
and putting those two things together
you can you can try to do you can take
novel attacks on existing security
problems that that already exist and
there is research going on on them we
are looking at three different problems
you're minimizing privilege for programs
that run today asset uid root protecting
application data from the ways of
preserving secrets of application data
monitoring kernel-mode rootkits and
there's a number of other ones that we
are interested in addressing to over the
long term and if anyone is interested in
anything in more specific details about
this I'd be happy to talk about that
with you so just a quick summary here
and I don't know why this boxes are
going great out but I've talked about
secure virtual architecture which is a
framework to provide a safe execution
environment for system software and in
fact potentially all of the applications
in software that renona system provide
the safe environment for programs that's
fully automatic it provides a safe
environment for the entire OS that
requires some porting effort but the
putting effort is relatively small for
an OS project and it enables higher
level security capabilities which I
think are a wide open research area and
if anyone is interested in specific
security problems that you would like to
explore I'd be very interested in in
collaborations if you are and it's the
safe experian environment solves the
first class of problems that I had
described in the in the three categories
that I described earlier
and opens up a whole number of other
problems that we can do research on so
let me stop there and and take any more
questions if you have any or if you want
me to talk about in more detail but any
part of what we did I'd be happy to do
that also so we're inside for two or
three questions
so you prepared your compared with
life's spin and copper was Java West
singularity oh a feature of those
systems is that they allow arbitrary
code to be loaded into the system and
then there's a decision procedure will
be accepted or will we not right whereas
in this environment you there may be
some boarding effort involved and you I
think you are assuming like cooperative
program so if you are you're increasing
this the safety of the mail demons as
XML HD video these things but is this
really suited for this environment where
you have adversarial programs that
beckons so I'm not sure why you're
saying well either that those systems
can check ahead of time that software is
safe they cannot do that because many
case in many cases they will do runtime
checks to guarantee safety properties
and bounds violations are a simple
example of that Java does a number of
runtime checks for safety including
array bounds violations null pointer
dereferences and so on right so they
sometimes discover runtime violations
just like we do the second part that I
don't think it's quite accurate is we
can run adversarial code in the kernel
to because we can detect ahead of time
if there is any code that we are not
able to analyze so in particular when we
guarantee that so when we take a program
and transform it with safe code and
guarantee that its memory safe and types
a partially type safe and so on that is
a strong guarantee the program cannot
violate that guarantee the guarantee
itself is somewhat weaker than water
then what a safe language would give you
because of dangling pointers but the
program cannot manipulate or corrupt
external data that was not permitted by
the surrounding environment to some API
so I know the binding modules yeah I
don't support binary in fact I am
justified to the fact that linux kernel
allows you to load modules so right so
he said I have to have some mechanism
for detecting that because underlying
architecture I mean you are using it x86
in distributing x86 so though if you did
sort of pick up that binding module it
would sort of run well so so Linux
allows you and other operating systems
allow you to dynamically load kernel
extensions right in fact Linux many
things are colonel extensions it alone a
file systems the network parts of the
network stack of device drivers but this
is why I was saying that it's important
that this is a look these these steps
are local operations we can perform
these steps on the dynamically loaded
module separately from the rest of the
colonel and so we can do this
verification and do dynamic loading of
modules without any problem we cannot do
that with native code this is not native
code the modules that we compiled to SVA
bytecode
if the extension in class
that he navigates you would just go
disable those checks because you
angel
so okay so there's two ways in which you
could rank on you could compile kernel
extensions ahead of time and one of
those would have that problem and and
another way would not the right way to
do it is that the colonel extension
itself is compiled along with the rest
of the colonel it's distributed
separately it's loaded separately right
and you can have multiple versions of of
this of a particular Colonel I so for
example could have multiple file systems
or different implementations of the TCP
stack and so on right but as long as you
compile the extension together with the
rest of the colonel then we don't have
any of those limitations we can do
checking for all of those objects but
what I was referring to at that point
was pointers coming in from external
code like user space programs like a
buffer coming in to print I for
something else right those objects are
completely outside the kernel itself
including expensive anything yeah
actually
separate
just for isolation yes is there some
support for that you could do that I
think it won't happen fully
automatically right now because either
because of the way the extension works
or because of imprecision and the point
analysis we might infer a particular
points to graph node that contains
objects both from the extension and
outside the colonel and from the rest of
the colonel right I think the point
analysis imprecision is the important
one there if the goal is that the
extension should not share any data with
the colonel then the first problem
doesn't occur but the point analysis
imprecision can occur one way to deal
with that is the programmers programmers
can modify the code to try to eliminate
the reasons for that imprecision and
dessert this is something that you can
provide very descriptive compile time
feedback on which which variables are
getting merged with pointers into pools
at that appear to come in from the
outside and simply by for example not
storing pointers in some in some in one
data structure but putting in a
different data structure or reorganizing
the data in a different way so incoming
pointers and internal pointers don't
have a merge you could get around that
so I think there would be additional
porting effort if you want to isolate an
extension completely in the sense that
it doesn't even have a common pool with
the rest of the car
we do guarantee now that the extension
cannot actually corrupt any data that
are not in the pool that it's accessing
and even in the pool that's accessing it
cannot do any bounds violation so it can
only access objects that it's cold that
was described directly in the code what
about the information flow within
different objects between objects the
same hormone thinking that is like my
social security number and your social
security number will be the same object
yeah that's something that we just this
is just not precise enough to to analyze
sofurry so if you wanted to be able to
track to isolate objects that we end up
mapping into the same pool you wouldn't
get that isolation but one thing to keep
in mind is if you're doing any kind of
compiler based technique to enforce that
isolation you have to do some point
analysis or some some such static
analysis to disambiguate those objects
right and if you can do that then in
fact we can make our thing more precise
so because since that if this system
choose not to change the egg here is the
surrey not to minimize the 40s and the
problem that see anybody requires that
you change the API so that
these policies we might think you know I
think for that for the second class of
security applications that i was talking
about their that for many of them
including information flow of denial of
service or certain kind of service
problems application data secrecy you
you have it's a research power to figure
out what is the right support that's
needed you you will need some
combination of new API is potentially
some programmer intervention actually if
you have new API is and certainly some
programmer intervention relational
possible additional compiler techniques
extension type system extensions and so
on it those things are much much more
sophisticated higher level security
issues and you know they don't come for
free by any means in any of these
systems
okay with that becker speech thank you